today's movie is a loose adaptation of a
manga by a famed horror mangaka junji
ito due to the darkness of his work he's
often dubbed the stephen king of japan
ito's horror is known to be more
disturbingly weird than terrifying he
doesn't deal in simple jump scares
instead his work makes you feel uneasy
and disturbed on a deeper level so fair
warning terror lies ahead we see
fishermen are busy with their daily
duties on a ship but a terror whelms
their faces after one look at the fish
elsewhere gauri is talking with her
fiance tadashi is checking on her over
the phone as they're in different cities
gary is on a vacation with her friends
aiki and erica in okinawa while
tadashi's in tokyo aki's a shy introvert
and i'm sure we anime fans can relate
while erica is the total opposite let's
just say she's more into the um carnal
pleasure of life
anyway after a long day of exploring
okinawa the girls head back on the way
they smell a horrible stench like a
decomposing body they ignore the smell
and head back to their lodgings to their
surprise as soon as they open the door a
gush of that same stench hits them in
their faces as soon as the girls manage
to vent out the stench aki notices a
rat-sized creature lurking around the
room now they're terrified but gary
pulls herself together and smashes it
behind the furniture the creatures are
freaking fish with spider legs and
nobody knows what kind of god forsaken
place it crawled out of gauri puts it in
a plastic bag as it smells horrible and
throws it in the trash
later that night she tells dadashi about
this weird creature to which that she
replies that he'll ask his big name
scientist uncle about it as they chat
the plastic bag with the spider fish
creature puffs and flies away the next
morning two cool dudes show up in their
lodgings to see erica who was quick to
make friends with them gary isn't okay
with this but erica she doesn't care she
calls the guys to a room and as they
start getting a little bit frisky the
guy smells something horrible now
obviously erica thinks that's kind of
rude telling a lady that she stinks but
it's not her it's a cgi shark with
spider legs behind them what an ungodly
combination the guys run out and the
hellspawn grabs erica skirt gary help
says aki cow's in fear i mean we can't
really judge her none of us have ever
been faced with a shark cross with a
freaking spider now have we after eric
is freed eike grabs her leg and asks for
help to which erica replies by kicking
her in the face again we can't judge
erica either because it's a freaking
shark spider hybrid right here in front
of her we don't know how people would
react after seeing that nightmare with
their own eyes anyway instead of running
outside and calling for help they go
upstairs and lock themselves in a room
it's a very high iq move there isn't it
i don't know why movie characters always
do this in movies it doesn't make any
sense the doors don't stop this freaking
terrifying cgi spider shark though the
hell spawn enters the room and stabs
erika with his spider leg things could
get worse but gary comes in clutch and
tricks the hellspawn into crashing out
of the window finally it falls and dies
but what's this the whole city swarming
with these hellish spider fish things
i'm sorry for actually criticizing gary
earlier it turns out not leaving the
house was a good call after all
everyone's terrified except reporters
who are reporting in the middle of this
they're seemingly unfazed the whole
country knows about this and tadashi
immediately calls to telkhari he's on
his way to okinawa but something attacks
him and the cause cut short gary panics
and decides to leave immediately for
tokyo back at the shed erica wastes no
time and takes on both guys for a good
time the world's in chaos and remember
erica's legs injured i mean i've heard
of animal instincts kicking in when
times are tough but god damn girl you're
something else aren't you downstairs we
see a different side of aki she's
cursing death upon erica and even gary
and she even hates erica for making
noises during a three hungary for
leaving her alone anyway on the flight
to tokyo ghari gets acquainted with a
freelance journalist named shirakawa
just before landing shirakumar notices
something horrifying surprise surprise
tokyo's also been overrun by these
hellish creatures even the runway
swarmed by these god forsaken monsters
so the playing crash lands although
everyone's safe gary quickly heads for
the monorail to get to tadashi and
shirakawa decides to help her in this
search it's quite heroic of him isn't it
right no actually he's only interested
in tadashi's uncle who's like an expert
on this epidemic
anyway the monorail crashes because of
the sheer number of creatures many die
but shinagawa and kari are safe they've
now survived a total of two deadly
crashes in the span of just a few hours
that's kind of impressive isn't it after
the duo decides to walkers that probably
feels safer on the surface they're
welcomed by the site of total mayhem
shark spiders killing people dead bodies
everywhere meanwhile gary gets a call
from tadashi they can't talk but at
least he's alive suddenly our old friend
spider shark shows up and attacks
shirakawa khari helps him to survive but
what's this after spider shark were
introduced to another hellish
monstrosity it's spider shark's cousin
spider octopus kun who snatches khari
and because it's an octopus in anime we
have this scene
this time shirakawa comes in clutch with
a pickup truck and rams it into spider
octopus [ __ ] the duo escapes back in
okinawa erika's not feeling well it's
probably because of the injury from
before it does get worse though and she
locks herself in the room on the other
hand aki's terrified of being alone so
she goes to check on erica as she enters
she's welcomed by that fine nostalgic
rotting smell erica hides under a bed
sheet and as soon as aki removes it
we're welcomed by yet another horrifying
sight from a beautiful looking young
girl erica's been transferred into this
ugly as sin extremely gassy ogre she
crawls towards aki and grabs her leg
just how aki grabbed hers during the
spider shark attack and just like erica
before her aki kicks her in the face
during this she starts spewing hate
stemming from her deep-rooted
insecurities about her looks she starts
showing her true colors her loathing of
her supposed friend erica and gary after
hearing this erica attacks it's a
scuffle and in the end aki hits her with
a freaking ashtray and leaves back to
karina they're closer to where that she
is but personnel dressed in ppe suits
have quarantined the area they
mercilessly push back our girl gary as
she desperately tries to get through
there's utter chaos on the streets as
people start looting robbing and killing
each other parallel to this the war with
the creatures is in full throttle
elsewhere shiragama and gary decide to
rest in a safe place to figure out their
next move they see an online broadcast
of people turning into ogre-like
creatures like erika it's due to a
bacterial infection they watch tadashi's
uncle giving his expert opinion on the
issue seeing that gary and shirakama
decide to visit him on the way there we
get a glimpse of our first spider humans
or rather spider ogres we should say
erika's turned into one too she's not
dead she's chasing aki the chase comes
to an end with aki falling into a pit
filled with small spider fish shirakawa
and gary reach tadashi's uncle's place
no one's there but gary notices
dadashi's shoes at the entrance and
frantically starts looking for him
before we go further let's take a moment
to look at this painting at tadashi's
uncle's place
who hangs up [ __ ] trash like this
anyway shirakawa finds a recent research
file on a computer there lo and behold
istanasi assisting his uncle researching
the bacteria in the video his uncle
explained some of the key things about
the bacteria these spider fish were the
result of imperial japan's desperate
effort to turn the tide of world war ii
they researched bacteria that causes its
host to produce a deadly and gross gas
but the creatures affected by this
couldn't do anything else other than
produce the gas so the scientists
developed mechanical spider legs any
infected creature could then hook up to
these legs and these legs were powered
exclusively with the gas and would allow
the creatures to reach and infect enemy
troops now you might wonder but how does
this gasket in the machine the answer is
to extract the fuel are pipes inserted
in the mouth as well as in the um uh you
know a place where the sun doesn't shine
anyway this research on the bacteria was
going on in a battleship and these fish
probably got infected because the
battleship was sunk by the opposing
forces the video also shows tadashi
getting stung by one of the lab
creatures seeing this scary panics and
runs for the basement where the video
was being shot being a true journalist
shiragama copies the videos on his pen
drive as evidence before trailing behind
her in the lab she sees a creature
standing still in the room a closer look
rendisgari paralyzed with sorrow it's
tadashi in a horrifying state suddenly
tadashi's uncle shows up at first he's
considerate but then he proudly
showcases tadashi as his creation ah we
should have seen this coming no normal
person would have something like that
hanging up on their wall
this guy is mad he's happy because his
personal gas powered spider legs
prototype is working as well as the
others he's fascinated by gas and how it
controls the machine on its own if it's
alive during this insane monologue
infected tadashi goes out of control and
stabs him through his stomach before
running away gary chases him or rather
it and even after shinagawa's plea that
tadashi is already gone the streets are
now overrun with infected humans and now
they're merging to form disturbing giant
machines not even guns work on them now
humans are losing this war the gas is
sentient now as it's grabbing the
infected and piling them on the giant
machines in the middle of this
incredibly depressing site shinagama
encounters a circus the ringmaster tells
him about gas being something
otherworldly as it takes on a soul-like
appearance when ignited so maybe it's a
superior life form these circus people
bring tadashi on the stage and gary
shows up too she calls him and he
approaches her like he remembers his
love for her but this weird romantic
reunion is cut short when the other
infected start attacking tadashi with
the tear in his eye he extends his hand
out to reach fulgari before being
horrifyingly ripped to shreds
after this shirakawa escorts gary to the
shore where the ship's leaving for
another country stationed however he
can't go with her since he's also
infected so he hands up all the footage
and the data he's collected in the hope
that it will benefit humanity someday he
admits to gary about his selfish motives
when he first decided to go with her who
was just looking for that click-worthy
scoop he wanted to get to dadashi's
uncle through gary the captain of the
ship reveals that these machines aren't
human-made as they don't appear to have
any screws or anything then we see that
humanity has lost this war and these
grotesque creatures are now all over the
world and on that incredibly painful
note
the film ends but there's a silver
lining though gary was also infected but
the virus doesn't seem to affect her so
who knows maybe her immunity can later
save the world
and with that the movie comes to an end
as does our video hope you enjoyed our
storytelling don't forget to like share
subscribe and share your feedback in the
comment section until next time peace